heading over to Saudi Arabia for a
conference and a speech we're connecting
in Abu Dhabi 3-hour layover it's been a
wild week I had an LA trip like this I
had an Australian trip like this I had
a thank you a Brazil Tri I just forgot
that was just last week August has been
very 2017 so a little throwback but
heading over for Esports gaming thing
obviously a lot going on in the Middle
East around pop culture soccer a lot of
culture but most of all like really
really focus on getting my work done on
a plane I think one of the things that's
really interesting about travel is the
ability to really catch up on work as I
head into Q4 Q3 and really try to end
2023 productively and really set up 2024
meetings in 2023 I'll work on a bunch of
vriends Business Development stuff a lot
of Vader X stuff some Vader sports stuff
some brain Gary Vista work we do that we
do
[Music]
that and I know that people that are 27
don't think they're young because 27
you're starting to smell 30 and when
you're 20 30 feels super old my cousin
worked for my father when I finished
University but I remember when I was 22
and he was 30 I thought he was a th000
when you're 25 when you're 23 when
you're 22 30 feels like it feels like a
big number but when you're 47 you know
how laughable that is because at 47 I
feel 25 I remember 25 like yesterday it
was the year 2000 I had to go to the
store and make sure Y2K didn't break the
computers I remember the day I was his
age and when I tell you inside my soul
inside my ambition inside my dreams and
hopes and wants I feel exactly like he
does so you can imagine how not worried
I am at 27 but you have to start
genuinely looking yourself in the mirror
and asking how much of your impatience
is predicated on outside opinions and I
would argue almost all of
[Music]
it in s what speaking no for me that's
enjoyable it builds brand it builds
awareness the very important opportunity
is in the practical sense of if I'm
wearing my CEO hat I need to be in the
region with offices with employees with
work in the region similar to how I see
the world whereas who's on offense
That's What attracted me to Silicon
Valley in the 2000s that's what attracts
me to everything that I look
at huge win for version one this is a an
Esports team that I'm part owner of with
uh the will family who owns the Vikings
so pretty proud of that
win so we've got professional footballer
and Esports Enthusiast Gareth Bale film
director and producer Michael Bay and
then finally last but not least we've
got Gary ve I think we can't have this
conversation without the acronym nft the
way nft is blew up and now there's a bit
of a stigma attached to it and I don't
think people really truly understand the
power of blockchain the issue that
happened with nfts is people forget that
that only 1% of things work only 1% of
films become iconic only 1% of iPhone
apps become successful and so what
happened was it was such a new
technology everybody thought all of it
was going to work when in reality only
1% of a genre can ever reach the levels
that people anticipated so it's cliche
human behavior the greed took over now
we reset but the macro technology of
decentralized servers will be one of the
most significant things that impact
everybody in the world and when you
think about the context of a country
like this moving so much faster than the
rest of the world I do think it's a
missed opportunity for people not to
take things like blockchain and Ai and
all the emerging technology serious
because that's where all the opportunity
lies in the next half decade and it'll
be interesting the next 15 to 20 years
where we're going to be at and how
people reacted to blockchain web 3 do
you remember this little thing there are
many people in this audience and around
the world that said they would never use
this because the Blackberry had buttons
on it and they needed their buttons
humans are very good at saying no to new
technology what all of us need to do is
you must be in the business of maybe
there are plenty of people in this
audience right now that have profound
opinions on AI and nfts and have never
played with it that is the issue at hand
in the world in technology most people
are not practitioners they're headline
readers Round of Applause please join me
thank you so much
impr
that went really well yeah
sure for me what's really important is I
don't like to rush into things either I
think context matters one of the things
that make me a challenge for my partners
is I prefer patience and collecting
context especially in a time of all the
opportunity in this amazing country I
have a sense from afar but I feel very
uncomfortable if I don't take multiple
multiple trips and be on the ground
before I think about what I want to do
I always still need to taste for myself
because to me my favorite part about
doing business is the
[Music]
relationship listen there's something we
think about all the time which is life
is not something you get to play again
it is a one shot game and every thing I
think about is mitigating and
eliminating regret because even if it
quote unquote doesn't work you even
going through the Journey is the win
because you cannot allow yourself in 30
40 years asking yourself sitting there
saying why didn't I do that and so it's
not risk it's actually the reverse the
risk is not doing and sitting with that
pit in your stomach for the rest of your
life so my answer is please go get the
jump we're cheering for you let us know
if we can help
[Music]
you vence and time is worth everything
fast food was about time not the food we
were willing to eat less healthy because
of time we're willing to compromise
that's right that's right the irony
that's how much we value time if you
could save time like it's everything if
I was the head of your marketing I would
probably sell on time over
everything wrapping up here in Saudi
very productive 36 hours what a month
this is just wrapping up crazy month
Australia Brazil La Saudi feels very
preo for me feeling uh energized and
focused and really just enjoying the
process you know even as hard as these
flights are as hard as it's to being
away uh when you're in your element and
creating and building a lane foundations
and Bricks Steel in the concrete to the
buildings you're trying to build in your
life they are uh quite enjoyable and so
no pain no gain uh enjoying it hope you
enjoy the Vlog talk
soon
[Music]